An ankle scope procedure, also known as ankle
arthroscopy, can be used to treat conditions
that cause pain or decreased flexibility of
the ankle joint.
The ankle is the joint that connects the leg
and the foot.
The ankle joint includes the two lower leg
bones, called the tibia and the fibula, and
the ankle bone, called the talus.
Together the ends of the tibia and the fibula
create a mortis, or a slot, for the talus.
Tissues called ligaments and tendons support
the ankle bones.
Ligaments attach bones to bones and tendons
attach muscles to bones.
The ankle joint allows the foot to move up
and down.
Articular cartilage on the ends of bones is
a smooth gliding covering that allows fluid
joint movement.
A variety of conditions can cause pain or
decreased flexibility of the ankle joint.
Abnormal bone growths, called bone spurs,
may have formed, impinging on the ankle joint
as it moves.
Ligaments may be damaged, either from overuse
or from ankle injuries, such sprains. Old
ankle injuries may stretch the ligaments,
allowing abnormal movement of the ankle joint.
This can lead to more rapid degenerative changes
in the joint.
Cartilage may be damaged or worn thin due
to prior ankle injury or osteoarthritis.
Small pieces of cartilage may have detached
from the underlying bone and may be floating
in the joint.
The joint space may be infected, usually from
bacteria.
To treat these and other conditions, a surgeon
may perform an ankle scope.
The surgeon will begin by making several tiny
incisions, or portals, in the ankle.
A small tube called a cannula will be placed
into one of the incisions.
A scope will be passed through the cannula
to allow the surgeon to see inside the joint
area.
The scope contains a tiny camera that will
project the image of the ankle joint onto
a TV monitor for the surgeon to watch.
A sterile saline solution will be pumped through
the scoped cannula, to expand the area so
the surgeon can see better and have more area
in which to work.
The surgeon will insert surgical instruments
into the other incision to do one or more
of the following treatments.
A bone spur will be removed or burred down.
Excess tissue will be removed from a thick
scarred ligament.
Loose pieces of cartilage floating in the
joint will be removed.
Infection in the ankle joint will be cleaned
out by washing the joint with fluid.
If a person has damaged cartilage or bone
from arthritis, ankle fusion will be performed.
During an ankle fusion damaged cartilage and
bone will be removed.
The bones will be attached to each other with
screws.
This will lock the ankle joint in one position
while other joints in the foot will continue
to allow limited movement.
Once the treatment is finished the sterile
saline will be drilled out of the joint, the
instruments will be removed, and the incisions
will be closed with stitches.